foreign
I saw this video our friends from the
Ramsay show I think Rachel Cruz was
filling in for Dave
and they played this video and reacted
to it so I wanted to also play because
it startled me and I've shown it to a
bunch of people now you haven't seen it
yet okay and it truly startled me it was
originally like this Tick Tock Trend
we're going to watch it and then you and
I will react Professor Sean go ahead
let's do it
Hey sir what is your car payment
uh mine is 13.25 and what kind of
vehicle is that it's a 22 Ford Raptor
okay you have another payment I do
actually my wife's hers is a thousand
it's a 22 Ford Expeditions
hey ma'am what is your car payment
13.86 and what kind of car requires a
1386 dollar payment a 2022 Grand
Wagoneer series three Perfect Hey sir
what is your car payment I got a couple
of them but the first one's 1445 yes
what kind of car is that that's a new
GMC Sierra 2500 Denali
what's the other one uh it's a wide body
CTS-V that's 11.61.
Hey sir what is your car payment
[Music]
what's your car payment and what kind of
car are you driving you know honestly I
was about to make my car back I don't
even show you it's kind of funny
everybody's talking about high payments
look at that number right there that's
my car payment
damn 2021 wide body Hellcat charger
Ryan we have to talk about this oh wow
so here's the thing
whenever you need something
it begins to control you mm-hmm and when
I need that new car
now all of a sudden it controls me in
various ways my
job I'm now Tethered to in order to pay
for the car to take me to the job so I
can pay for the car that takes me to the
job yeah
isn't it funny how we like tell
ourselves well
at least I'll enjoy my ride to work
I'm like that's how we justify it I'm
gonna buy this really nice how I did it
at least I'm gonna buy this really nice
ride so I can at least enjoy the car
time that I spent and the more
promotions I got in that company the
more I had to be on the road so I could
just justify it even more yes yeah no
but it is a it is a weird little cycle
when you lay it out how you just did it
yeah when I had a luxury car back in the
Audis I had several a couple lexuses a
Land Rover none of the payments were
nearly as high as these yeah that's I
was shocked over a thousand bucks is
crazy and so in the one guy in the red
shirt he was spending twenty five
hundred dollars a month on two separate
cars that's rent that's a really big
house mortgage like in the midwest like
it's that's crazy and so
you have to also couple that with all
the gas that goes into those Vehicles
the insurance payments the gap insurance
the interest rate
etc etc there's so much money we're
spending on these things that then
become a prison now I'm sure all of
their cars are nicer than my nine or ten
year old Toyota right
and yet you know what is nicer than all
of that the freedom that I don't have a
single car payment I don't have to worry
about
constantly going to a job to pay for the
car to take me to the job and so this
isn't a judgment of these people this is
a judgment of a system
that is fundamentally broken if I have a
car payment it means I couldn't afford
the car in the first place
however I could have afforded
a beater
I could have driven a 500 car a thousand
dollar car a two thousand dollar car I
could have saved up for it at some point
and then gotten the car that will take
me to work and then I can upgrade from
there if I so choose but needing the
upgrade now I'm in the control of the
financiers of the car dealership of the
sales person they control my life the
car controls my life the debt controls
my life and it's overwhelming
this Tick Tock was by a car dealership
what do you think they were trying to
achieve yeah I'd love to know the
purpose of this I I can tell you exactly
what they're trying to achieve look
everyday normal people this is just
normal right thirteen hundred bucks
fourteen hundred dollars for a car
payment look it's normal now so come on
down to Jim Bob Chevrolet or whatever
they're driving yeah and now you can be
normal too
you can and by the way these weren't
even impressive cars it wasn't like it
was a Lamborghini right not that that
would impress me at all I mean the
hellcat's pretty cool but still I don't
even know what that is that a tractor
it's uh
suffice it to say I'm unimpressed let's
just say it is a tractor it's a it's a
it's a muscle car basically fair enough
yeah well there's something to tick tock
Danny you can figure it out no that is
that's that's unbelievable that like
it's normalized and that's is what
they're trying to do they're trying to
normalize over a thousand dollar a month
car payment and I remember I wanted to
buy a Lexus
um
oh I forget what that's how old was yeah
yeah one other like special models makes
and when I went to the dealership the
payment was 600 bucks a month
and I just wasn't willing to do it and
and uh yeah I I couldn't imagine saying
yes to a thousand dollar a month car
payment well
the best thing you can do when it comes
to your car pay cash because here's the
thing is that a it makes you safe over a
period of time so Mariah and I we had
the 2004 Toyota Corolla which by the way
when I got that
um it was right when I got laid off from
work and I had to get rid of my car
payment because I was like oh like now I
don't have an income so you know I'm
gonna get rid of as much debt as
possible so I sold my car got rid of
that car payment and I'll tell you like
that 2004 Toyota Corolla like I enjoyed
that
way more than the fancy car I had
because of the freedom of not having to
pay a monthly car payment and man we
went on tour in that thing and it was
great we know a bunch of Tours in that
we went on a bunch of Tours in that
thing and so you know getting back to
paying cash for your car uh you got to
save up so you got to get a little bit
of discipline but the thing is is when
when you save up 10 15 20 000 uh you
know Mariah and I had saved up over you
know five six seven eight years to get a
to get the car that we have now and it's
painful to drop that much cash and what
that does though is it prevents me from
it prevented me from you know uh uh
trying to get a nicer better car I
always talk about the Tesla and I
remember like at a certain point I went
to I'm like I'm just gonna do it man I'm
gonna like I'm gonna dump all my stocks
and I'm just gonna like pay cash for the
Tesla and you're like really you want to
spend that much on a car yeah and uh you
know thank God I've got you to talk some
sense sense into me sometimes whether I
listen or not but it wasn't you
shouldn't do that right it was a true
curiosity of wow you're really gonna pay
that much for a car yeah not that it's
wrong and by the way someone who makes
millions of dollars can afford any of
those vehicles and they can pay cash for
them and it's not a problem but think
about some of these car payments right
if cars fifteen hundred and sixteen
dollars that's the last car there
fifteen sixteen
I suspect that person if they had just
eighty thousand dollars in the bank they
wouldn't say I'm gonna give this eighty
thousand dollars for this car exactly
and if you wouldn't do that then I also
wouldn't Finance it yeah did you enjoy
this Standalone patreon highlight if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free